[Music]
sir Jordan and the entire dream team are
back and they are going to destroy our
realm one house at a time
sir Jordan seeks to permanently end the
debate to prove he is the goat of goats
it's no use
there's not a house in this realm that
could beat the dream team you're right
that's why we've got to build one so
without further ado I will announce the
members of the super super house hereby
known as the knights of the round ball
as selected by the Masters of the media
del Sol where is this big battle
supposed to take place tonight we ride
for Seattle
[Music]
then our enemy doesn't tire they don't
manage their loads their fundamentals
are perfect and they don't get
distracted by social media Ravens expect
relentless hand jacking and ruthless
physicality not exactly your best pump
up speech there doc how much practice
time do we have our scouts say they'll
be here before dome groupies cluster
they're all masters of the positions so
we go position this it'll confuse them
we're gonna have to be hyper efficient
attack the rim or stay back behind the
arc ranges let them fly from deep early
it'll force them to respect our spacing
yes I will hit them with a barrage of
step backs and my passing ability will
make them go wow I've never seen this
from a big man now make sure to come up
with some wily [ __ ] that will get
them technical fouls right
you tell the refs the minute you see
what are the tunics come on Todd we'll
need every edge we could get against the
dream team we could try going to three
and force them into a long game of zones
no 90s rules that would be a legal
defense crazy idea here but we could go
small Mike no look we have the talent we
have the skills and we have the strategy
but the reason I know we will prevail is
that we've got the ultimate weapon
analytics no you oh yeah no I've got
this you go right for the heart you take
sir Jordan one-on-one and push his ass
around if he falls they break you want
to prove you on the goat this is your
chance yeah yeah nope no problem I mean
it's just Michael Jordan right you know
what you were excuse me for a second I
actually have to take my talents to the
chamber pot oh thanks he's got this
hello everyone welcome to the first ever
meeting of the Order of the all-seeing
eye now of course by I I mean me I am
all see in case you didn't know I'm a
genius I invited you all here not
because we're friends but because we are
part of a spiritual house one built
around our shared hatred of a common
enemy
playing defense Oh guys Terry Kevin to
run no guys no you were all here as
victims of great snobbery excluded from
all realm teams harassed by ignorant
families chastised by Analytics blog
boys living in their parents dungeons
but let us wallow no longer in the
backcourt of despair for the shot clock
on our slander near zero where I have a
dream a vision of a realm with no haters
no hot takes and no Ravan trolls sowing
the seeds of disunity realm where we can
just play basketball in peace but first
we must destroy that which stands in our
way the mediator but isn't the media
devil too powerful what's your plan
Kyrie doesn't need a plan draymond he's
an artist he improvises I'm an artist
Kevin you never let me do what I want
yes I did I left so that you could take
whatever stupid shots you please this
group's gonna destroy itself before it
destroys the media Dale well then we
better get started follow me
hey you went to the bench feeling heated
down from his poster boy over the booze
of the crowd and the whistles they all
heard his famous cry you can get two
shots when a soft night flops but a poor
will never lie poor she could plead or a
refs play death that a poor will never
lie that was actually quite good damn
yeah for a night Wow
yeah your musician is not great but for
a night it's pretty legit now Oladipo
whoo
he's good for a bard like oh yeah oh my
god when you played thingamajig it's in
the mess singer oh my god oh yeah yeah
his voice is so good it makes my arms
blush alright well if the realm is
ending tomorrow I've got some things to
take care of James you should get some
rest
you're going to bed something like that
what was that about he's going to a
brothel
what did seven house was that I'll tell
you for Brooklyn house Nets held from
Jersey but the families were few so the
Lords of house Nets attempted to rebrand
they designed a new court new tunics
armor and a new mascots but some thought
this new mascot was just too cool that
the realm wasn't ready for something so
totally radical swamp dragons that's a
myth is this another one of your
conspiracy theories see for yourself
hey Kyrie what's up back yeah you
brought some cool dudes
sup dudes I hear you guys want to
totally wreck the media I'm down I'm
sure that kind of frustration in front
of sir Jordan it's like blood in the
water
Oh looks like we've got a Jordan expert
over here you could say that Kobe I
figured I could be of some service great
you want to help us defeat Jordan but
you've always worshiped him I he
inspired me but I kneeled to no man I
serve the good of the realm you must
continue to move the game forward King
James you are my legacy those Knights in
there they are are lazy
I sense doubt look I know I have the
size the skill the power but this is Sir
Jordan I mean the guy scored 38 points
in the finals when he had the plague yes
he's a killer and defeat him one must
become a killer well what I cut away all
your distractions cut away self-doubt
insecurity once you have removed all
that does not serve you in battle
you've found your mom before I'm I'm
sorry I I don't think I understand I'm
saying you need to shave your head it's
a shirt
the world is going to end tomorrow and I
don't even know how to begun I heard
that our world was made when the gods
smashed two universes together that's
why it doesn't make much sense
you know LeBron what happened to you
so what you think looks good finally
okay whoo because I just saved off like
40,000 gold worth of hair potions what
are you seven hells
they're here
Holt sir Jordan and this now before you
embarrass yourself
wait what you want doing here it's not
safe it is now for how Sun Kings will
defend the realm
what's the Sun King we are newly formed
super house comprised of the best nights
from house sons and house Kings alone we
wallow in eternal mediocrity but
together we stand toe-to-toe with anyone
you should leave now before it's too
late
the dream team will be here any minute
well then Sun Kings ready yourselves
guys guys I can't watch you get
slaughtered let me join you we don't
need you we have the under-18 and who
was the guy we took over Luka Jared
Jackson Northern Bagley Marvins Bagley
yes
[Music]
Sun Kings flame your balls what I'm not
gonna say it Sun kings
well there goes eight easy wins yes I
would absolutely take Jahlil Okafor over
Ben Simmons um can we talk about how
we're being attacked by Russell
Westbrook right now huh Russ attack in
the media what else is new
come on he shoots 20% from the outside
wouldn't be too concerned I don't care
about the numbers I mean he's got that
killer instinct I would have taken a
fire dragon
[Music]
all right I have a little pump up speech
I prepared you know what actually guys
I'd be showing you all short if I read
from the [ __ ] so I'm gonna go straight
from the heart if you also believe the
old heads our enemy hails from an era
far superior to our own they are Slayers
of giants ochres and Dragons untouchable
immortal they are the gods of this game
and we should just get on our knees and
thank them for the rights to live in the
shadow but against the hollow ghosts of
the past the future is the it's Colonel
underdog today we fight with the wind at
our backs and those gusts howl with the
cries of legendary Knights yet unborn
now I could go on but all generation
doesn't have the attention span for that
so let's go out there and show them what
efficient basketball looks like my
fellow gods of tomorrow we are the dream
teams night
[Music]
you